users can get connected with your app in
many different ways from recommendations
from family friends or colleagues
searching an app store or using a search
engine research done by Google and ESO
found that about 52% of app users
surveyed found new apps through family
friends and colleagues 40% through just
browsing an app store and 25% through
search engines so you can think beyond
just the App Store to get your app out
there you're gonna want to get family
friends and colleagues talking about
your app and sharing it so there are a
ton of different distribution channels
to give your users access to your app
but what's right for your business now
here are some ideas to kind of get you
started well you can consider having
your app pre-loaded into a phone no I'm
sorry Apple and Samsung probably aren't
going to come beating down your door
just to load your app on their phone but
you can pay for it pay a lot that is
it's pretty expensive your app will be
pre-loaded onto a specific mobile device
and people will just be exposed to it
and they're more likely to actually use
it so the conversion rate for these
pre-loaded apps is significantly higher
than average you can optimize your own
website make sure to have a widget that
can be pasted onto a mobile website or
Facebook pages for example that will
take your users directly to your app or
you could create a mobile web version of
your app now creating a mobile web
version coded in html5 is a great way to
enable wide distribution outside of just
the smartphone audience also people can
engage with your product before they
commit to downloading it which is a much
higher commitment on their end and don't
forget about the marketing workhorse
email you can also consider just
emailing links to your app to your users
we'll go over many more options later in
the course but I want you to get started
thinking about these things start
getting creative because when it comes
to marketing ideas sky's the limit